four home runs in a game a year ago
yesterday one of just 18 players in
baseball history to do it
we should have seen this coming our good
friend scooter Gennett the red second
baseman is back with us where are you
right now scooter we're uh at the Great
American Ballpark right now you got the
Rockies Nattie yeah you got the Rockies
coming up in a couple hours
yeah yeah got the Rockies and then we
got the Cardinals coming in so big
weekend ahead
what's the pregame spread bear in the
locker room oh it's different it's
different everyday it's it's it's pretty
show though Dan probably probably better
than what you got in your pregame talk
showed me a lot I would say we got our
own chef he's big-league Wow yeah he
hooks it up he you know he can do a
custom type meal for you if you're not
feeling what what's out there but
yesterday was let's see bacon
cheeseburger for me so you know I'm not
complaining at all well 1 for 3
yesterday I'm looking through numbers
here this is all star quality stuff
you're hitting 340 for 12 homers 44 RBIs
we're penciling in and we're gonna see
you in DC at the all-star game I'm
assuming scooter that'd be great
that'd be great um you know it's it's
one of those things where you know
they're starting I take the starting
lineups up to the fans you know and then
the the rest of the guys the players and
coaches are you know involved and
picking the rest of the guy so do you
want to go because if you just say the
word and I'll make it a help I mean I I
think everybody wants to go including
myself I would love to go at the would
be great I mean I got ken griffey jr. in
an all-star game one year I mean that's
how powerful I am
I got trout in Hartford so okay you're
the next one up so scooter Gennett Reds
second baseman when you go to the
ballpark
make sure you punch in his name just so
we put those stats on display 344 12
homers
what is the best thing that has happened
in the last year based off of your four
home run game oh man gifts they gave
they actually got me a national scooter
but Yamaha goes like 55 I actually I was
going down the hill he's and given a
little pest off the road and and I
turned before the bottom of the hill it
was like grass and it tossed me off
landed on my side didn't feel very good
so I decided to donate it back and the
Reds have the Community Foundation and
they raised the money they raffled it
off and I gave it away a couple weeks
ago to a lucky guy that want it so you
know I'm gonna probably retire from the
two-wheel nice life and stick to four
wheels what did you tell the training
staff when you came in off that injury
well I I wasn't injured I was very sore
basically it was probably a clothing to
like you know me running at like a Billy
Hamilton type speed and slamming into
the wall on my left side yeah yeah I
definitely won't want it's not possible
for me to run that fast but I would say
that's what it was equivalent to it
didn't feel good I got on up I moved my
it was my left side I moved you know
some like my left leg my left shoulder
and and everything was intact but the
next day it was you know it was I was
pretty sore but I I didn't say anything
you know I didn't think that be you know
a good look and I ended up doing pretty
good the next game so not to say that
I'm just gonna you know fall off the
scooter before every game but but no I
wasn't injured or anything and you know
I told him a couple weeks later what
happened
and then there's scooter Gennett
bowhead with you on a scooter that's
coming up this weekend yeah that's big
time that's big time I think um I think
a lot of kids will probably end up
break-in the scooter off of the off of
the thing and playing with it like a toy
my head will probably end up off you
know that's it's it's pretty unique
though it's um you know it's a different
type bobbleheads good for you we were
curious best pitcher you faced this year
is who have you faced Scherzer yeah we
faced him opening day I got lucky a few
times off of them but he's I mean he's
he's special you know he's got obviously
has great numbers but there's a there's
a reason I mean he throws four pitches
with command and you know can put the
ball wherever he wants it throws
backwards or you know it's like you
don't see a fastball when you think
you're gonna see one type of deal and
you know when he got 95 9 he's such to
go with it it's it's not fun yeah but
you're hitting over 300 so you own
Scherzer so let's move on to it like a
like a really good pitcher and there's
so many good ones nowadays it's crazy
trying to take a one that stands out
they face the Cardinals guy that throws
105 I did I faced him I faced him shoot
early in the season
yeah that's not very fun it's it's 100
but it moves like a foot so it's like
come on man like it should be illegal to
throw pitch like that I feel like if you
saw that hard it should have to be
straight and it's not then it's like you
know just a ball even if you swing in
this or you get out like it's just all
right let's redo it the deal I think you
know to me like let's say you face
syndergaard and then you face Jordan
Hicks who throws 100 fun what's the
difference between 99 and 105 check the
math on that he's correcting ok 6 miles
an hour all right now is there a big
deal
noticeable difference and six miles per
hour yeah yeah I mean it's it's it's
just you man it's it's just an added
it's more like late you know out of the
hand at all looks somewhere it's just
you know you're starting your hands and
then you're like man that thing's by me
in it and I feel like the first time you
see it it's like man like this has
topped the head and then more you see it
and that's what makes him him tougher
because you're only seeing him once you
know once a game maybe maybe once a
series you only getting one at-bat
against Hicks but you're able to see
spin regard that the next step bad you
might get a three at-bats against
underwear it's you just see more and
you're able to adjust because you know I
would say the average fastball I mean
nowadays it's probably why I like 93 to
95 to where you see a 99 it's just a
little extra and you're like okay like
you just got start a little earlier and
then you know you're able to adjust but
when you're only seeing that closer you
know once or twice a series that's you
know that's what makes them that much
better because you don't really have
have enough you know time to to adjust
to it but it's it's just it's really
fast it's really really fast but if
everybody was throwing 105 it would be
normal so it's just what you're
accustomed to seeing and and you know I
think back in the day you know guys it
was like a four-man rotation they
weren't thrown as hard to where you know
then they see a 97 it's like wow like
it's so much faster but you know if
they're seeing that I'm a regular
regular basis it would be somewhat
normal
he's scooter Gennett the red second
baseman fill in your all-star ballot and
consider him batting 340 for 12 homers
44 RBIs got the Rockies coming up in a
couple hours
would you what's it like with a
knuckleballer we don't have as many
knuckleballers now have you faced one
yes yeah I have it can really mess you I
mean there's there's some that I got a
sticky a few times and it's like you
just have to whether you do good
you just have to forget about it you
know because it's it's something where
if you get frustrated or like man and
you're trying to like me you know like
really adjust to it and hit it like you
you know you're getting frustrated like
no I'm going to stay on it and then all
of a sudden you're you know the next
game you're facing a normal pitcher and
it's like it takes a couple games to be
like oh you know what let's get back to
this so you can get embarrassed with a
knuckleball derp like if you whip at 105
then we go man okay but but if if that
knuckleball and everybody looks at it
goes why couldn't you hit the
knuckleball yeah it's it's crazy man the
biggest thing is you don't know what
it's gonna do you don't know if it's
gonna stay sometimes it knuckles and
then it looks like it's gonna drop and
it stays straight and then sometimes it
you know it's up in the zone you're like
oh that's gonna flat now and it just
goes down in the dirt you just it's so
unpredictable I mean there's a lot of
catchers that they can't catch it you
know and and they know what's comin
they've caught them you know they've
seen probably a couple hundred pitches
from the pitcher and they still can't
catch it so I think the best thing to do
is to probably next time I faced the
knuckleballer I'll probably get up you
know up in the Box closer to the pitcher
to try to try to take away some of that
late movement I think that's probably
the best bet but really it boils down to
lay just don't get don't get too
frustrated like don't have super high
expectations to where you know if you do
get embarrassed you're like oh whatever
you know I'll just wait till he's out of
the game and you know start over well
the last celebrity you saw one of your
baseball games
[Music]
well Nick Lachey was actually at a game
of ours in LA and I guess someone must
know somebody on the team or somebody
left them tickets and he was in like our
family section well here's mom used to
work for the Reds well then that's
probably it he's a big Reds fan and and
he was there and my wife was was at the
game and like she doesn't really care
too much about baseball which is which
is good you know coming home she's like
oh good game I was like over it I'm like
Jesus
you know it's good that's what you want
you know but she was at the game and and
literally I had to hear about it for
like hours after the game like oh my god
like I've never seen her like so excited
about like going to a game or you know
just after the game was just Nicolas a
the Nicolas say that I'm like oh my god
what's your why me
was your wife more excited about Nick
Lachey or your for home run game
Nicholas Janis first sure like after
that game the for Homer game I came out
and like it took a while because they
were authenticating all my stuff and you
know it took a while for me to get out
and she was waiting for me after the
game and I come out and she's like hey
like great game you know and I'm just
like I even realized but yeah a hundred
percent more excited about the Nicholas
shape thing she's got a picture with
them so I mean that like made her season
right there so I mean yeah well she's
got her priorities yeah yeah for sure
she's she's uh she's in a she's in a
good spot I hope I hope she doesn't run
into Justin Timberlake or you're in
trouble yeah I mean that's I guess it's
um I'm just gonna put her up in the
nosebleeds in other words have fun today
and hopefully we'll see you in DC at the
all-star game scooter good to talk to
you again absolutely then always a
pleasure and yeah I hope to see you
there man
all right scooter Gennett red 2nd
baseman hitting 344 for more Dan Patrick
show to the audience Channel 239 on
DirecTV or download the Dan Patrick show
at
[Music]